I used to actually do I used to be a  rapper and growing up is there a little  of that  alright alright well this is I can't  your dad ready three two one  we're the partners or I'm the Legion of  Doom when we're on stage sucka MC's make  room for us because they know that we're  the best  I'm the pineapple crush is MC kid fresh  so when we're on the mic we never lose a  fight in the light of day or the still  at night flying higher and farther than  all the competition when we're on the  rhyme we do it with precision not  bragging saying but we're about but they  can listen to my jam there'll be no  doubt that we are the best you've ever  seen because our rhyme with style yes I  reign supreme  I'm the real educated rapper runnin  connoisseur and vocabulary master you  wanna do a puff will you do with me  though doing once and then I'll say okay